sie sei eine schlechte launepartei die
AFD so der Bundeskanzler nach dieser
Lesart nimmt die Zahl der schlecht
gelaunt im Land aber beständig zu
ausweislich der Meinungsumfragen zu
Parteien und Wahlverhalten die
Rechtspopulisten liegen bei knapp 20%
gleich auf mit der Kanzlerpartei SPD wie
gesagt noch sind es Umfragen aber die
nächsten Wahlen kommen bestimmt höchste
Zeit für die Gegner der AFD sich etwas
einfallen zu lassen oder mal
Selbstkritik zu üben vielleicht denken
dann manche potentiellen
afd-wählerinnen und Wähler noch mal nach
AFD im Umfrage hoch woher kommt der
Zuspruch jetzt in der phönix-runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
zugeschäumt aus Bonn ist Reinhard
Schlinkert der Gründer von infa-test
dimap dem demoskopischen Institut das
unter anderem die ARD mit dem
Deutschland Trend beliefert Maria
Fiedler ist stellvertretende Leiterin
des Tagesspiegels des Tages Spiegel
Hauptstadtbüros hier in Berlin sie
schreiben über Union FDP und
Innenpolitik und seinem Buch geschrieben
mit dem Titel die Methode AFD alexander
ist Redakteur in Berliner Büro der neuen
Züricher Zeitung bekanntlich eine
Schweizer Zeitung und das heißt der
Redakteur Redaktor
der Traktor Alexander bei uns und
Professor Werner Patzelt ist
Politikwissenschaftler und
Forschungsdirektor des Brüsseler Büros
des ungarischen singt Tanks Matthias
cordonius Kollegium also einer
Organisation oder einem Institut für
politische
Analysen Herr Schlink hat AFD und SPD
sind im Moment in Umfragen etwa gleich
auch so ungefähr bei 18
19%. ist das eigentlich eine
Momentaufnahme die wir gerade erleben
was die AFD die wählerkunst der AFD
angeht oder ist es bereits ein sehr mehr
viel Erfahrung damit wie sich
demoskopische Umfragen wenn sich
Umfragen dann sozusagen verfestigen
können und wieder raus Wahlergebnisse
werden
naja die Leute die wir jetzt gefragt
haben die gesagt haben sie wählen AFD
sind natürlich nicht alle diejenigen die
dann auch zur Wahl gehen das wird man
später sehen aber interessant ist ja das
bereits im letzten Trend den wir in
Thüringen gefahren haben das war im
August 22 da war die AFD in Thüringen
schon stärkste Partei aber da hat sich
noch nicht jemand so stark aufgeregt wie
das jetzt ist was jetzt auf bundesweiter
der bundesweit auch angekommen ist in
Brandenburg haben wir die AFD auch bei
23% jetzt im April gehabt auch noch ein
bisschen stärker also schon als die SPD
gleich auf mit der CDU das sind Trend äh
der nicht erst seit gestern da ist er
passend kommt die AFD jetzt aus der
politischen Schmuddelecke raus oder
haben einfach immer mehr Wählerinnen und
Wähler kein Problem mehr mit dieser Ecke
ich glaube dass die Sache mit der
Schmuddelecke den Kern des Problems
nicht trifft der kennt das Problem ist
scheint der zu sein dass viele unserer
Politikern von der
Migrationspolitik früher von der
euro-rettungspolitik sind zur Energie
und Klimapolitik bei einer nennenswerten
Minderheit der deutschen Wählerinnen und
Wähler nicht auf großen Zuspruch stoßen
und nachdem sämtliche etablierten
Parteien von der CDU über die SPD und
die FDP bis hin zu den Grünen an diesen
Politiken festhalten wollen sagen sich
viele er dann ist die einzige Partei die
wir wählen können die Alternative für
Deutschland er gesagt wenn man schon mal
bei Umfragen sind nur noch 20% sind mit
der Arbeit der Ampel im Moment zufrieden
erklärt dass das Umfrage hoch schon
hinreichend der AFD das ist ein
dramatischer Befund für eine
Bundesregierung in der Mitte der
Legislatur die anderen muss ich sehr in
der eigene Nase fassen und mit
Sicherheit ist mehrheitsfähig die
Auffassung dass man momentan schlecht
regiert werden davon profitiert
natürlich zunächst eine Opposition und
innerhalb der oppositionslandschaft
profitiert dann jenepartei stark oder
stark zunehmend die auch innerhalb der
Opposition als kontrakraft erkennbar ist
die CDU hat einfach das Problem dass sie
eben für viele der jetzigen Zustände
mitverantwortlich ist dass eine Partei
Mitglied ein Partei Mitglied namens Frau
von der Leyen bei der EU-Kommission in
Führung der Spitze steht insofern die
cdu/cs immer das Problem haben sich auch
ein Stück weit von sich selbst
distorsieren zu müssen um der Ampel
richtig Kontra zu geben diesen Nachteil
sozusagen hat die AFD nicht weil sie
einfach noch nie irgendwo politische
Verantwortung getragen hat und desto
leichter kann man fordern dass wir
weiter man von der tatsächlichen
Gestaltungsmacht entfernt ist so viele
die anderen Oppositionsparteien in der
Tat ähm besonders die Union können von
der Unzufriedenheit der Wählerinnen und
Wähler mit der Ampel nicht profitieren
oder kaum profitieren oder liegt das
also es gibt jetzt auch mittlerweile
selbstkritische Töne aus der Union man
fragt sich warum man nicht über die 30
Prozent hinaus kommt obwohl ja die Ampel
erkennbar Probleme beim Regieren hat und
eine Erklärung hat jetzt beispielsweise
der Generalsekretär der CDU in
Schleswig-Holstein geliefert der sagte
die Union werde womöglich nicht als
konstruktiver Alternative zur Ampel
wahrgenommen das ist sicherlich auch nur
ein Faktor hat gesagt sie haben gerade
einen anderen Punkt genannt aber die
Krawall Rhetorik die auch aus der Union
zu hören war in letzter Zeit er hat
wahrscheinlich nicht dazu beigetragen
dass sie als konstruktiv wahrgenommen
wurde also ich sag mal nur ein Beispiel
Energie Stasi als es um das Wärmegesetz
der Ampel ging und dann hat die Union
natürlich auch ein Problem weil
Friedrich Merz wahrscheinlich nicht auf
so viele Wähler wie Sie sich das
wünschen
würden sympathisch erscheint also bei
der Kanzler direkt weil hat letztens die
BILD am SONNTAG nur Umfrage gebracht hat
20 Prozent Olaf Scholz auf 25 und da
liegt Friedrich Merz einfach hinter den
Umfragewerten seiner eigenen Partei das
ist natürlich auch ein Problem Leute
sagen Spitzenpersonal der AFD gilt auch
als sehr sehr unsympathisch also hupala
und Weidel sind fast immer am Schluss
des Rankings also die haben auch ein
personalführungsproblem trotzdem wird es
übertüncht von dieser starken
Oppositionskraft teils Protest teils
programmatisch aber in der Tat ist es 14
Personal gerade bei Oppositionsparteien
ganz wichtig und im Übrigen sollte man
sich nicht an diesen Kleinigkeiten
direkt vielleicht falsch ist ob der
spitzenkarte hat zu schlecht aussieht
oder zu übel überkommt oder ob die
Opposition die konstruktiv genug ist an
diesen Faktoren die Kleinigkeiten
erklären Kleinigkeiten sehr wohl aber
nur Kleinigkeiten nicht allzu lange
aufhalten das Kernproblem oder die
kernerklärung scheint mir darin zu sein
dass die CDU nicht mehr eine Partei auch
derer im Lande sein will die sich rechts
von der politischen Mitte empfinden die
CDU will eine Partei nur noch der
politischen Mitte sein und nun gibt es
nun mal auch Rechte im Lande und die
Rechten haben sich nun beschlossen
hinter der Fahne der AFD zu versammeln
das scheint mir ein ziemlich klarer
Sachverhalt zu sein für den vor langer
Zeit schon der Begriff der
repräsentationslücke geprägt worden ist
und wenn man den nicht im Auge hat wird
man immer nur an Symptomen herum zu
operieren versuchen er Schlinkert er ist
das entspricht das auch ihren
Ergebnissen dass viele in der Union zu
sehr die Mitte bemängeln und dass man
doch sag mal so Mitte rechts sein möchte
also das nennen das mal anders das
nationale das konservative wieder mehr
in den Vordergrund stellen sollen
ja das ist ein anderer frage ich muss
aber noch mal ganz kurz auf unseren
Schweizer Kollegen eingehen dass hier
nichts Neues dass eine Bundesregierung
nur 20% zufriedenheitszahlen hat das
haben wir schon gehabt als die Union mit
der FDP dran war 2010 haben wir das
gehabt wir haben ganz niedrige Werte
gehabt als die Union und die SPD wieder
dran waren 18 also so ganz ungewöhnlich
ist das nicht dass wir so niedrige
Zustimmung so schlecht gewesen
da komme ich jetzt gerade drauf man muss
sich vorstellen Olaf Scholz fing mit
ungefähr 60% Zufriedenheit an jetzt ist
er hat er sich halbiert das gleiche bei
Robert Habeck hat sich noch mehr als
halbiert
eine Frau berberburg hat sich auch etwas
halbiert noch ein bisschen weniger
Christian Lindner hat auch wesentlich
weniger bekommen und Friedrich Merz
verharrt so in den Bereich 30 und unter
30 jetzt 26 25 Prozent das heißt das
Spitzenpersonal überzeugt nicht und bei
der Thematik wir haben wir auch gefragt
warum wählen Sie denn die AFD jetzt mit
unserer letzten deutschlandtrennt im
Juno da haben immerhin zwei Drittel
gesagt weil sie sind von den anderen
Parteien enttäuscht und was spielt ihre
größte Rolle bei der Enttäuschung
Zuwanderung Migrationspolitik
Energiepolitik Umwelt Klimapolitik und
dann kommt erst die Wirtschaft das heißt
die Frage der Emigration wo ja auch nur
die CDU probiert wieder doch sehr
strikte
Vorstellung zu haben was die Asyl
Gewährung an den Grenzen aus den Grenzen
der EU angeht ich glaube da probiert die
CDU sich nun im Moment wieder ein
bisschen weiter die Union ein bisschen
weiter aus der Mitte hinweg zu bewegen
aber das ist eines der tragenden Themen
die wir im Moment sehen also doch nicht
geschlossen an der Stelle das muss man
ja dazu auch
noch wir sehen zwar eine Michael
Kretschmer der jetzt grundlegende
Änderungen des Asylrechts ins Spiel
bringt aber wir haben auf der anderen
Seite auch Hendrik wüst oder Daniel
Günther die dann viel liberaleren Ansatz
fahren bzw da eben auch mehr noch auf
der Merkel Linie sind und bei Friedrich
Merz changiert es immer mal so wir haben
ihn gehört wir von kleinen Paschas
gesprochen hat da gab es dann auch aus
der Partei deutlichen Widerspruch das
hat er dann so nicht wiederholt aber man
merkt schon es gibt da keine eindeutige
Linie
ist auch ein bisschen komisch wenn Sie
eine einheitliche Linie hätte die weil
ist ja sozusagen ein Markenzeichen der
Union der CDU immer gewesen verschiedene
politische Richtungen zu bedienen aber
Frau Hitler was ist denn das
Hauptproblem vor allem der Ampel ähm
noch mal betrachtet ist die Politik dazu
abgehoben ist zu verkopft gibt's dazu
viel Streit in der hat der Koalition zu
viele Baustellen dann momentan
gibt's dazu viele Baustellen was
also jetzt z.B Energie ich glaube das
Hauptproblem ist das Vertrauen in die
Handlungsfähigkeit der Ampel hat massiv
abgenommen und in die
regierungskompetenz der Ampel also wenn
sich eine Regierung permanent streitet
wenn sie sich auch gegenseitig blockiert
also Stichwort heizungsgesetz da kommen
wir sicherlich auch gleich noch mal
drauf wenn dann die FDP sagt nein das
tragen wir so nicht mit aus inhaltlichen
Gründen wo sie auch Punkte hatten die
richtig waren die Grünen dann wiederum
sagen ja dann blockieren wir wieder was
anderes das hat das bietet ja ein
fatales Bild für die Wählerinnen und
Wähler und wenn man dann kein Vertrauen
in die Handlungsfähigkeit der Regierung
hat dann kann das natürlich sich auch
auswirken auf die auf das Vertrauen des
politisches System insgesamt
einfach laufen er hat jetzt auch gesagt
Streit ist kein Werbung und der wünschte
sich dass manche Debatten etwas leiser
ausgetragen würden aber er tut nichts
dagegen also er bewegt den Eindruck dass
jemand der eine dreierparteienkoalition
nicht führen kann auch führungsschwach
ist natürlich auch im Auto
passend ist die ist das chaotische vor
gehen der Ampel weniger dass man jetzt
sagt die sind so abgehoben eine
abgehobene Elite sondern dass sie
einfach eine ein Politik Angeboten
machen praktisches Politik angeboten
dass die Leute verstört
dass die Ampel zerstritten ist ist nicht
das Hauptproblem das gießt sozusagen nur
noch ein wenig Sahne in den Kaffee
hinein das Hauptproblem ist dass vieles
an der ampelpolitik nicht so
Wirklichkeit passt schauen Sie der
fundamental-pazifismus von Grünen und
finden Sozialdemokraten ist zerschellt
am russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
das ist eine 180 Grad Wende sogar eine
Zeitenwende ist das geworden da merkt
man das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht mit
dem was diese Leute so lange so
sympathisch gemacht hat dann kommt die
Sache mit Klimaschutz dass man dafür ist
es selbstverständlich aber dann wird das
runtergebrochen bis hin zur wärmepolitik
oder zur heizungspolitik und jeder
bemerkt was das im eigenen Alltagsleben
macht es ist einfach so dass die
Politikern die unsere politische Führung
machen will sich zwar sehr gut machen in
Partei Zetteln unter schon überzeugten
sie machen Sie gut auf Partei Tagen sie
machen sich gut im Wechselspiel mit
Journalisten welche Sache ähnlich sehen
sie machen sich aber nun Wirklichkeit
nicht allzu gut und jetzt sehen wir
einfach viele
illusorische Ideen Blasen an der rauen
Wirklichkeit zur Schellen und an dieser
Stelle sind die Bürger natürlich besorgt
ob die Regierung wirklich so gründlich
darüber nachgedacht hat was sie machen
will und dann kommt der Streit sekundär
dazu denn das muss ich dann innerhalb
der Koalition streitet was ist denn nun
wirklich richtig was nicht was steht im
Koalitionsvertrag was musst du unbedingt
gemacht werden was jetzt sozusagen
Verrat am Koalitionspartner dieser
Streit ist dann selbstverständlich und
er freut die Bürgerschaft nicht
sonderlich schlanker darf ich da
vielleicht kurz anschließen an das was
er Patzelt gerade gesagt hat
wie sehen denn die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die politische Führung die
politische Klasse wie immer man sie
jetzt nimmt nennt nicht nur das ist im
Moment die Ampel Koalition so schlechte
Werte hat sondern wie wie empfindet man
die Arbeit auch das Verhalten die ganze
Performance der politischen Klasse in
Deutschland
ja ich wollte jetzt eigentlich noch auf
zwei ganz interessante Werte aufmerksam
machen wir haben das lange nicht mehr
gehabt dass nur zwei Drittel der
Menschen in Deutschland sagen dass ihre
dass die eigene wirtschaftliche Lage
sehr gut oder gut ist das ging ab Januar
19 runter das hat man vorher nicht
gehabt das ist parallel dazu wie man die
wirtschaftliche Lage in Deutschland
einschätzt die schätzt man auch schlecht
ein es schlechter ein als das vor
gewesen ist die Mehrheit zwei Drittel
sagen die ist schlecht das war auch
lange lange Zeit nicht der Fall die
Menschen sind wirklich verunsichert und
wenn es bei den Heizungen um die Heizung
geht dann mache ich dann machen sich die
Menschen sorgen dass ich dass sie
geplanten Maßnahmen zur klimaschonten
heizen mich finanziell überfordern
werden auch wenn etwa das die Zustimmung
zu den Heizungen etwa 50/50 in der
Bevölkerung ist die Menschen sehen schon
dass da was passieren muss aber sie
sagen das überfordert die sind total
verunsichert und sagen noch zusätzlich
bei den ganzen Fragen um die Heizung
geht es natürlich auch darum dass ich
die eigenen Parteien die Parteien in der
Dreier in der Ampelkoalition selbst
profilieren wollen und wenn sie dann
noch so schlechte Zustimmungswerten zu
den Handeln Personen haben zu der ganzen
Regierung haben dann ist natürlich
völlig klar auch dass sie was gerade
gesagt wurde was den Kern der Grünwähler
angeht sympathische Partei man fühlte
sich gut wenn man sie wählte man macht
ja nichts Schlechtes und inzwischen
sieht es da ja auch anders aus dass auch
sehr sehr viele grüne Wähler inzwischen
ihre Stimme nicht mehr bei den Grünen
geben die haben wir nun deutlich
deutliche Stimmenverluste bei der
letzten Wahlen gehabt sowohl in Berlin
als auch in in Bremen und es mir fällt
ihnen immer schwieriger mit ihren
Vorstellungen in die Mitte der
Bevölkerung reinzukommen
dass die Koalition sich darauf geeinigt
habe das Gebäude Energiegesetz noch vor
der Sommerpause durch Bundestag und
Bundesrat zu bringen da sieht man wie
also die Niederlagen von heute die
Katastrophen von morgen gerade so
heraufbeschwören man hat sich nicht
geeinigt weil es wirklich in der Sache
kompliziert ist jetzt will man
Handlungsschnelligkeit und
Entschlossenheit demonstrieren und das
Ergebnis ein Hoch umstrittenes Gesetz
soll mit gewissen Retuschen
durchgepeitscht werden als wird sich
irgendwas dran ändern wenn man das jetzt
erst nach der Sommerpause macht also sie
kommen in der Nacht aus dem
nachbesserungsmodus nicht heraus und
schaffen dadurch neue Probleme das ist
also sehr sehr problematisch und dazu
scheint mir noch folgendes gesagt wir
haben zu müssen diese allzu große
Beschleunigung in der Politik die sie
jetzt beschrieben haben die fängt ja
schon an mit unserem Ritual der
Regierungsbildung die einzige Zeit in
der in Deutschland grundsätzlich über
Politik und Strategie nachgedacht wird
das sind die Koalitionsverhandlungen wo
jeder der Koalitionspartner versucht hat
war von seinem Wahlprogramm möglichst
viel umzusetzen da werden dann
Kompromisse gemacht das ist gut aber es
wird auch kompromissformen dann einfach
den drechselt die dann unter dem Druck
der Wirklichkeit ab und instand halten
und weil nun einmal im Koalitionsvertrag
der Sache mit halb so und Energiesparen
drinnen steht muss es irgendwann gemacht
werden zumal auch immer wieder überprüft
wird wie viel Prozent dessen was im
College Koalition ist denn schon
abgearbeitet aber das ist nicht das
Zentrum das Problem
was jetzt die im Moment den Zustand der
Koalition angeht und wie sie
unfreiwillig auch der AFD möglicherweise
hilft jetzt gibt es ja plötzlich
massiven Druck von der grünen Basis in
Sachen migrationspolitiker hat vorhin
gesagt das ist für viele Wähler der
Mitte und rechts der Mitte was das
Hauptthema das soll jetzt also äh Stück
dagegen gehalten werden gegen einen
Kompromiss auf EU-Ebene das EU Asylrecht
so zu vereinheitlichen dass jedenfalls
illegaler Flüchtling vermindert wird
also Kontrolle an den Außengrenzen
Verfahren einen Außengrenzen jetzt
treten die grüne Basis quasi als auf
also auf stur und ist das nicht einfach
auch dann das Problem dass die Ampel
damit noch schwereres fahrwassergerät
jetzt natürlich die Frage auch wie sich
die Grünen Minister wie sich die Grünen
Spitze da verhält aber die sind
natürlich im Dilemma ganz klar sie haben
eine Basis die zum Teil ziemlich links
tickt die jetzt auch Sorge hat dass da
an den EU-Außengrenzen Lager entstehen
dass da illegale pushbacks vermehrt
stattfinden und auf der anderen Seite
haben wir eben auch die koalitionslinien
denn sie Feser will sich jetzt dafür
einsetzen das ist eben das ein
gemeinsames europäisches Asylsystem gibt
das da auch mehr Kontrolle an den
Außengrenzen stattfindet
Kompromissbereitschaft erfordert ja und
es wäre natürlich was was auch Seehofer
nicht geschafft hat was Nancy Casa jetzt
schaffen würde also aus sich von Nancy
Casa wäre das auch ein Erfolg wenn das
jetzt funktionieren würde und die Grünen
sind jetzt eben in dem die Lämmer
einerseits linke Basis und Linke grünen
Wähler vor den Kopf stoßen andererseits
die andere Möglichkeit wäre ja das ganze
blockieren und da könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass das natürlich auch von
Seiten der Union dann massiv genutzt
werden würde auch um gegen die Grünen zu
schießen also es ist eine tatsächlich
schwierige Situation
jetzt haben wir ja darüber gesprochen
oder gemutmaßt was die Leute alles nicht
wollen an der aktuellen Politik vor
allem in der regierenden Koalition aber
was wollen Sie denn eigentlich ist dass
er patzel den Leuten klar denn die was
hat denn die Alternative für Deutschland
die sich ja alternativ nennt weil sie
Alternativen anbieten möchte nach
eigenem selbstverständlich eigentlich zu
bieten an alternative an alternativen
politischen Inhalten an alternativen
politischen Inhalten ist anders als
Beschreibung von wünschenswerten Zielen
wenig bei der AFD zu finden das ist aber
auch nicht verwunderlich denn eine
Partei die ohnehin in der nächsten 10
Jahren irgendwo in der Regierung
beteiligt sein wird steht auch gar nicht
in Notwendigkeit praktikable Politik
Konzepte zu entwickeln das muss die AFD
und die Wählerschaft der AFD in erster
Linie will ist eine Begrenzung und
Steuerung der Zuwanderung in der
Europäische Union und dabei eine
Reduktion des sozialen Magnetismus
unseres eigenen Landes das was die
Wählerschaft und die AFD gerne hätte
wäre dass die Inflation wirklich wieder
zurückgeht wozu wo es wahrscheinlich
auch beitragen muss dass die Europäische
Zentralbank ihren naja flutungsprozessen
mit Zentralbank Geld zur Behebung von
budgetären Problemen manche europäische
Staaten einstellt aber dann immer hinaus
der AFD also darüber hinaus ist nicht
viel an konkreten zu sehen denn dass das
Bildungssystem auch marode ist und dies
und jenes mein Gott also damit kann man
in Deutschland weil das auch Ländersache
ist bundespolitisch keine großen
Eindruck machen wenn man das bei der AFD
auch in den Zeiten in die Migration ja
eigentlich nicht das Mega Thema war so
in den Jahren so zwischen
2018/2021 war es für die AFD Wähler und
die potenziellen AFD Wählerinnen und
Wähler eigentlich immer das wichtigste
Thema auch wenn es gar nicht so für
viele bedrohlich erschienen ist das
überhaupt Thema der oder die Hauptthemen
erstens Migration zweitens Migration
drittens Migration in der Migration ohne
Kritik stehen schon am Wiege der parte
das ist ja völlig klar und natürlich war
der Abwärtstrend in den Jahren die sie
beschrieben hat auch damit
zusammenhängend dass eben Migration in
der Phase nicht das große Megathema war
und man es nicht geschafft hat andere
Themen an die Seite zu stellen für den
corona-protesten die man sich gehängt
hat beispielsweise kaum profitiert jetzt
kann man wieder sagen Migration ist
schon immer unser kernesset ja das
stimmt sie können sagen Sie haben im
Programm auch eine Debatte auch gefüllt
wird Kernkraft also mit uns wäre die
Energie billiger weil wir in Energie Mix
hätten aus deutschen Kernkraftwerke und
russischen Gas und das verfickt
natürlich auch bei einigen die sagen es
ist zu teuer was ich hier momentan
zahlen muss und weil ich vielleicht in
Zukunft zahlen muss wird noch mehr sein
die AFD ist und bleibt natürlich ein
Fieberthermometer der Krisen die die
anderen verursachen das heißt je mehr
Leute sich dafür theoretisch entscheiden
umso mehr geben Sie den Regierenden zu
bedenken tut mal was in der Migration
überlegt mal deinen Energie Mix oder das
neue Werding was ausgegeben hat wer sind
die Partei des Mittelstands und des
Handwerks weil natürlich auch durch
Rettungspakete und Klimaschutz
Initiativen viele kleine Betriebe in den
Eindruck haben den großen wird geholfen
und die kleinen lässt man laufen also da
versucht man zu zeigen was sie anderen
schlecht machen aber ich komme noch mal
zum vorhin zurück ähm es ist momentan
nicht mal erkennbar dass sie AFD
irgendwo und Bürgermeister ein Landrat
geschweige denn im Ministerpräsidenten
stellen würde also muss sie sich nur die
nächsten fünf sechs sieben acht neun
Jahre auf jeden Fall damit bescheiden
immer Stopp zu sagen und eine möglichst
große Menge an stop mitsagern hinter
sich zu versammeln
aber da gerne auch noch mal einhaken
wollen also ist jetzt aber auch nicht so
dass auf die wählen eine reininhaltlich
getriebene Angelegenheit wäre also man
sieht ja auch und das Sagen
Politikwissenschaftler das afd-wähler
rechtspopulistisch populistisch ticken
das heißt da ist auch das die Meinung
oder das Gefühl da es gäbe da einen
Willen des Volkes der gegen eine Elite
ja durchgesetzt werden müssen und ja
also das ist was was alle afd-wähler
auch größtenteils gemeinsam haben das
darf man an der Stelle auch nicht
vergessen klingt AFD Wähler sind das
Protestwähler
oder sind das überzeugungstätter
jedenfalls in was weiß man über die das
Profil dieser Wähler Bescheid
ja man muss natürlich auch sehr
unterscheiden afd-wähler ist nicht
gleich afd-wähler auf die wir denn
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist was anderes als
ein AFD Wähler in Sachsen oder in
Thüringen wir haben es ja in Bremen
gesehen wo die AFD ja nicht antreten
durfte zu Wahl dann haben die Bürger ein
Wut mehr als zehn Prozent auf einen
bekommen aber wenn man sich anschaut wie
die Strukturen sehen so sehen wir das
also ganz wenig ganz wenigen westlichen
Bundesländern die AFD die Höhen erreicht
die sie in östlichen Bundesländern
erreicht zweistellig relativ leicht aber
die wählerstruktur ist relativ ähnlich
es sind meistens die Altersgruppen
35 bis 40 die ziemlich stark AFD wählen
und dann auch noch mehr Männer als
Frauen aber die Gründe im Westen sind
nicht viel anders sind protestwälder die
von anderen Parteien enttäuscht sind wie
sie sagen im Osten kommt noch ein
bisschen mehr dazu
fühlt man sich ja immer noch und
benachteiligt als Bürger zweiter Klasse
fühlt sich nicht vertreten von den
Politikern egal wer der an der Macht ist
ob das der die Linke in Thüringen oder
die CDU in Sachsen sind aber was wir
sehen ist da wo ein starker
Ministerpräsident ist da ist die
Altersverteilung ein bisschen anders da
sind die mittleren Altersgruppen nicht
so stark bei der AFD wie sieht das da
sind wo der Ministerpräsident nicht so
ein hohe Zugkraft hat aber
eins ist klar der Anteil der
Überzeugungstäter oder der Chance hätte
überzeugungs Wähler ist sicherlich in
den OST in den neuen jemals neuen
Bundesländern höher als in den
westlichen Bundesländern weil wie ich
gerade sagte auch noch andere Gründe
mitspielen wie Enttäuschung die Frage
überzeugungs Wähler ist das eine das
andere sind die vielleicht doch
Denkzettel verpassen oder protestieren
es gibt ja nun der Landesverband in
Thüringen die jungen Alternative sind
nach Verfassungsschutz Überzeugung
gesichert rechtsextremistisch ist das
für viele Menschen die die AFD wählen
oder vielleicht sich überlegen die AFD
zu wählen nicht mehr so wichtig wen sie
da wählen und dass diese diese
rechtsextremistischen Tendenzen ja in
der Partei tatsächlich vorhanden sind
weil das sind natürlich ganz dramatische
Befunde wenn man sagt das gesichert Rex
extremistisch ist nicht nur
extremistisch also da der klingt ja
schon die die Bereitschaft zur
Gewaltausübung mit also es sind schon
sehr sehr starke Aussagen und natürlich
führt es zur distorisierung war bei
Staatsdienern beispielsweise bei Beamten
vielleicht auch bei bei Feuerwehrleuten
etc pp anders als muss natürlich merken
dass diese sukzessive Beobachtung der
unterhalten war noch mal passiert worden
ist natürlich auch in gewissen
Gewöhnungseffekt erzeugt hat bei denen
die mit sympatisieren was überlegen
können Sie sagen na ja also ich
repariert das jetzt nur die sagen ja
der Markt die halt nicht die können
machen was er wollen und höcke macht
sich schon lustig drüber sagt lesen Sie
bei mir im Telegramm Kanal mit dann
könnt ihr euch schon lesen was einem
halben Jahr im Verfassungsschutzbericht
drin steht also es ist heute gelungen
auch in einem gewissen Klientel den
Verfassungsschutz die Legitimität
abzusprechen und leider Gottes ist
manchmal der Verfassungsschutz Unterhalt
über manchmal auch selbst erweck
zumindest den Eindruck übereifrig zu
sein so dass dieses Schwert zwar heute
sehr häufiger gehoben wird als früher
aber in den Augen dieser Wähler viel
schwächere Klinge hat und das ist schon
ein Problem nach dem Motto ähm ist der
Ruf erst ruiniert Welt ist sich ganz
ungeniert aber trotzdem und auf den Teil
sollte man schon auch gucken gibt es
eben einen nicht kleinteilern
überzeugungs WLAN die eine in Teilen
rechtsextreme Partei wählen und wo die
AFD auch machen und sagen könnte was sie
will die würden die trotzdem wählen also
das ist ein Befund den wir ja seit
Jahren sehen und ich finde das sollte
hier in unserer Debatte auch nicht
unterhalten
nur acht oder zehn Prozent auf die dafür
zutreffen vermutlich auch Ost-West
unterschiedlich aber ja also was sie
sagen stimmt natürlich es hat aber
Zahlen darüber was was an Protestwählern
und überzeugungsfehlern da wie sich das
verteilt unter der Wähler also in Zahlen
der Wählerschaft
in der in der Republik insgesamt zwei
Drittel Protest Fehler ein Drittel wird
das Überzeugung aber ich wollte Ihnen
noch eine andere Zahlen nennen wir
machen auch immer alle zwei Jahre in
Sachsen sehr sehr große Umfrage in
sachsen-monitor und in Sachsen gibt es
vier Prozent Ausländer und wir fangen
dann ganz viele ganz viele Items ab es
ist eine face to face-umfrage 2000 Leute
wirklich ganz solide und das
Verblüffende ist dass bei 4% Ausländern
ist immer eine Gruppe von über 20% gibt
die sagt mein Wohnumfeld ist in starken
Maße von Ausländern überfremdet das
verwundert wie die eigene wie die eigene
Rezeption der Situation ist also mit
prozentualen Wahrnehmung hat das gar
nichts zu tun das ist ein Gefühl was
viele Menschen haben und deshalb wollen
wir schon mal gesagt viele Menschen
fühlen sich da ja auch abgehängt im
besten fühlen sich auch viele Menschen
abgehängt und sie können also auch sehr
klar sehen bei den westlichen
ganz klaren Verlauf was Bildung angeht
die geringer die Bildung desto stärker
innerhalb der FDP weil AFD Wähler die zu
der der Zugang zu AFD je höher die
Bildung des so geringer das ist im Osten
anders
der richtigen Beobachtungen ist glaube
ich noch folgendes hinzuzufügen
wir sprachen von dem einen Drittel
sozusagen überzeugter afd-wähler zwei
Drittel wären sozusagen noch greifbar
wenn Ihnen Angebote gemacht werden aber
es ist bei uns inzwischen so weit
gedehnt dass der Begriff rechts
rechtsradikal rassistisch faschistoid
sehr stark entgrenzt worden ist viele
Leute die von sich subjektiv ist mit
Nazis haben wir überhaupt nichts am Hut
und ich bin auch kein rechtsradikaler
sind mit dem Etikett du bist ein rechter
ein Rechtsradikaler so intensiv versehen
worden dass inzwischen eine weit
verbreitete Haltung ist die haben mein
Gott dann bin ich eben eine
rechtsradikale und dann kann ich ganz
ungeniert die AFD wählen und das sollten
wir im Kopf haben wenn wir von den zwei
dritten AFD werden sprechen die die AFD
wählen ohne sozusagen ein gefäßt
rechtsradikales Weltbild zu haben
infolgedessen müssen wir auch auf unsere
politische Rhetorik achten wenn wir
denen die wir eigentlich zu den
etablierten Parteien zurückholen wollen
ständig verbale Fußtritte verpassen und
ihnen sozusagen menschliche
liquität und politischen Verstand
einfach
schematisch absprechen dann werden wir
an dieser Stelle nicht erfolgreich sein
das haben wir nun jahrelang gemacht und
heute wundern wir uns warum die AFD
trotz der ständigen Kampfes gegen Rechts
und der Ausgrenzung bei 28 Prozent ist
wir haben wahrscheinlich was falsch
gemacht
zwei Drittel in Deutschland auch das
eine neue Umfrage haben tatsächlich
Angst vor einem Rechtsruck ein Drittel
hat es nicht es gibt zwei Umfragen
nahezu parallelen Ergebnissen das heißt
also das Bewusstsein welche Rolle die
AFD auch spielt in der politischen
Landschaft ist bei vielen Menschen also
bei einer klaren Mehrheit vorhanden das
ist ja nach wie vor keine Partei der
jetzt die Herzen von ganz Deutschland zu
fliegen sag mir auch nicht vergessen wir
reden hier vom Umfrageergebnisse von 18
bis 20 % von einem stabil nach oben
gerichteten Aufwärtstrend aber man sagt
mir jetzt auch noch nicht ne das wird
die Partei Landschaft irgendwie auch an
anderen Stellen im beeinflussen nur noch
mal da verstärken daran erinnern woran
es gescheitert ist letzten
amerikanische Präsidentin wurde weil sie
von dem der privates gesprochen hat den
abgehängten und ich glaube man kann
natürlich soziologisch beobachten davon
sprechen aber wenn man den Eindruck
vermittelt als Politiker den politischen
Wettbewerb besteht das sind die
abgehängten die sind halt abgehängt dann
verfestigt man ja auch den
Selbstzuschreibung wenn man also sagt es
sind halt die die als Politiker das sind
die bildungslosen die abgehängten oder
manche haben schon gesagt ja das läge an
der ddr-erziehung Design im Prinzip
nicht mehr Demokratie fähig dann
produziere ich trotz und ich glaube
Erwachsene Politik wäre Argumente zu
bringen und nicht trotz zu provozieren
und da habe ich schon den Eindruck dass
mit solchen Zuschreibungen wie schlechte
Laune Partei ähm herr Schulz sich da
keinen Gefallen tut momentan ist die AFD
nicht schlechte Laune Partei für ihn
weil sie eben gleich hoch ist das Buch
die Methode AFD geschrieben was bei der
AFD immer wieder auffällt dass sie ja
mindestens also jetzt mit aktuellen
Vergleich mindestens so zerstritten ist
wie die Ampel das scheint Dir aber nicht
zu schaden also nur ein Beispiel
Bundestagsfraktion wegen der Russland
Politik da gibt's ja richtig im Gebirge
im Moment
der schlittenheit scheint ihr aber nicht
zu schaden ich würde sagen da hat sich
was geändert bei der AFD also zu Zeiten
wo Herr Meuthen noch da war da sehr
ständig gekracht und das glaube ich hat
ein Stück weit schon geschadet dieser
dieser zerstrittene Eindruck das ist
jetzt aber vorbei klar in der
Bundestagsfraktion wird in Sachen
Russland Politik auch heftig diskutiert
das bringt aber gar nicht mehr so stark
nach außen und diese wirklich heftigen
macht Kämpfe zwischen
radikal Rechten und etwas weniger
radikal rechten die finden ja so nicht
mehr statt weil die Frage eigentlich
geklärt ist innerhalb der Partei und ich
glaube das ist sicherlich auch ein Punkt
von dem die Partei profitiert
jetzt ist ja die Partei ist gerade für
schon mal angeklungen gegründet worden
ist aber von Westdeutschen westdeutsch
sozialisierten Professoren im Jahre 2013
die eine
marktliberal bis marktradikales
staatsfernes Weltbild haben denen die
damalige Koalition aus Union FDP viel zu
Links waren inzwischen ist die Hochburg
aber
in Ostdeutschland für diese Partei
erpatzl ist das eine ostdeutsche Partei
ist sie noch eine westdeutsche vermischt
sich da ostdeutsches und westdeutsches
wo liegt die Zukunft der AFD
Frankfurt zunächst einmal nach der
Vergangenheit denn aus der ergibt sich
dann meistens Vater abhängig manches in
Bezug auf die Zukunft schauen Sie in
Ostdeutschland gibt es Seite
Wiedervereinigung den Eindruck dass das
westdeutsche System auch nicht ganz das
Gelbe vom Ei ist das auch nicht alles
wohl geraten ist dass viele es an
westdeutsche Politik in der Praxis sich
gar nicht so gut auswirkt wie es klingt
diese Besorgnis
auch angesichts mancher westdeutsche
Arroganz wie mit ostdeutschen umgegangen
worden ist ist früher von der PDS ganz
wunderbar zum Ausdruck gebracht worden
wenn man auf Wahlergebnisse geblickt hat
hat sich dann immer bei der PDS die
Silhouette der DDR abgezeichnet
inzwischen ist die PDS auch durch ihre
Ausdehnung in den Westen zu einer ganz
normalen deutschen linken Partei
geworden die das Schicksal alle sehr
linken Parteien in Deutschland teilt
nämlich irgendwann unter die 5% höhere
zu rutschen die Funktion Protest gegen
ein System zum Ausdruck zu bringen in
die hat sich die AFD hinein gesucht
hinein gearbeitet das zentrale war dass
die AFD nachdem sie 2013 knapp den
Einzug in den Bundestag verfehlt hat
sozusagen auf der Suche nach einem neuen
Geschäftsfeld war und die afd-führung
gauland und so weiter haben 2014 in
Dresden ganz präzise nachgesehen worüber
erregen sich heute aus deutscher am
meisten sie regnen sich am meisten dass
sozusagen ihre vertraute
halbwegswiderstabilis Lebenswelt durch
eine ungesteuerte Einwanderung verändert
würde insbesondere Muslime wurden
gefürchtet deswegen auch die
patriotischen Europäer gegen die
Islamisierung des Abendlandes gauland
hat wie andere Beobachter gemerkt dass
hier der Eindruck die eigene Lebenswelt
verändere sich eine große
Mobilisierungskraft entwickelt auch wenn
es gar nicht furchtbar viele Ausländer
und Muslime in Ostdeutschland gibt und
hier hat dann die AFD das zentrale
mobilisierungsthema gefunden und weil
die Westdeutschen Reaktionen auf den in
Ostdeutschland aufkommenden
Rechtspopulismus ziemlich taktisch
dämlich waren nämlich dann die
Ostdeutschen als Dunkeldeutschland
gescheiterte Stadt nicht reich zu
Demokratie zu bezeichnen hat der Protest
dann auch noch eine gewaltige psychische
Dimension gewonnen wenn man das begreift
dann begreift man warum die AFD heute im
Osten bei 28 + X Prozent steht und im
Westen bloß bei 12 plus X Prozent
ein Gedanken dann noch aufgreifen die es
gibt ja eine wenn ich das richtig im
Kopf habe diese Grafiken direkte
Wählerwanderung in den letzten Jahren
vor allem bei Landtagswahlen in
Ostdeutschland von der linken zur AFD
kann man sagen dass die AFD die Linke da
auch als Ostdeutsche kümmererpartei
abgelöst hat vollständig abgelöst hat
eher vollständig nicht sonst würden die
auch die Ergebnisse bei den Umfragen in
Thüringen nicht nach wie vor auch noch
ein ganz gutes Ergebnis für die für die
Linken haben
eigentlich noch
ja klar der ist hat ja auch noch ganz
gute Zustimmung was sehe ich hier gerade
muss ich mir gerade reingucken da sind
auch mehr 53% zufrieden mit ramelo ganz
sicher bezahlen links aber vielleicht
eine Zahl die uns alle ein bisschen
ermutigen kann wir haben auch im letzten
Monat oder was in diesem Monat gefragt
jetzt mal abgesehen von welcher Partei
sie uns jetzt gesagt haben die Sie
wählen würden wenn jetzt Wahlen wäre und
wir wissen ja selbst an die 30 Prozent
sagen uns im Moment ich weiß gar nicht
was ich wählen würde ich weiß gar nicht
wo ich tatsächlich hingehen werde aber
wenn wir das gefragt haben und dann
gefragt haben und was können Sie sich
vorstellen welche Partei könnten sie
denn sonst noch wählen und welche Partei
würden sie auf gar keinen Fall wählen
dann fand ich sehr überraschend der 77%
der gesamt Wahlberechtigten und nicht
nur derjenigen die ich schon wissen was
sie täten fassen weil wäre uns gesagt
haben also die AFD würden wir auf gar
keinen Fall wählen das ist interessant
weil diese Zahlen bei den diese Parteien
bei der CDU bei der SPD immer so um die
50 Prozent sind dann bei den Grünen und
bei der FDP so um die 40 Prozent da
haben die Grünen ganz ordentlich
verloren im Vergleich zu dem was vorher
da war aber die Zahlen bei der AFD sind
eindeutig und sie sind sicherlich und
das ist jetzt auch in so Diskussion hier
wieder rausgekommen ganz eindeutig hat
das was mit der Unzufriedenheit zu tun
und auch wie
gesagt auch was mit der ja sehr nicht
gerade positiven Umgang mit den
Problemen die im Osten in den neuen
Bundesländer waren man hat es wirklich
abgetan als
davor ihr habt neue Straßen und schöne
Häuser sonst seid zufrieden und dankt
uns wird schicken auch jedes Jahr 100
Milliarden Euro zu euch also wir dürfen
doch gar nicht böse sein müsste doch
eine einige unsere schönen Parteien
wählen aber was wir gesehen haben wir
auch in Sachsen-Anhalt als gibt es einen
guten Ministerpräsident der hat stark
mobilisiert mobilisiert auch ein
bisschen sich selbst gegen den Westen
gegen die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
Rundfunkgebühren der wurde doch ganz
schnell und gut gewählt mit seiner CDU
ja natürlich auch wie schwierig ist dann
an solchen Personen festzuhalten also
Herr rammelung muss jetzt unbedingt noch
mal in die Bütte Haseloff musste noch
mal antreten also irgendwann hast du
dann auch wirklich Kenntnis das ist
Zeichen dass sie sagen was man als
Brandmauer gegen die AFD bezeichnet vor
allem bei der Union aber ja
bröckelt diese Brandmauer nächstes Jahr
kommt es ja zum Lackmustest
möglicherweise sie haben so vorhin
gesagt sie werden noch längere Zeiten
Opposition behalten aber hält diese
Brandmauer vor allem der Union wenn wir
jetzt die vielleicht nicht den
Brandenburg aber die Wahl auf die Wahl
in in Sachsen und in Thüringen wo die
AFD ja stärkste Partei ist zumindest in
den Umfragen jetzt
hält diese Brandmauer dann oder gibt es
doch möglicherweise einen Versuch ein
Bündnis zu schmieden vielleicht keine
Koalition aber tolerierungsbündnis
also ich kann meistens eigentlich nicht
vorstellen weil man es doch jetzt den
Mund so voll genommen hat also das wäre
ja wirklich dann der organisierte
Wahlbetrug wenn man danach sagt das ist
Mama doch irgendwas mit der mit der AFD
ja das glaube ich nicht aber ich glaube
nicht dass die die Brandmauer da AFD
gegenüber auf allen Ebenen auf alle
Zeiten halten wird das glaube ich
einfach faktisch nicht wenn du gemeint
hast und eine Landratswahl ansteht oder
ist jemand im Ort verankert da wird es
irgendwann auch mal in den nächsten
Jahren ein Landrat geben von der AFD ist
ja schon ein paar mal knapp gescheitert
ähm das wird hier und da passiert und da
wird man schauen ob sie sich komplett um
und als unfähig erweist oder ob er
vielleicht seinen Job gar nicht so arg
schlecht macht nur auf einer Bundes
Ebene und einer Landesebene wird diese
sogenannte Brandmauer ich halte das Wort
etwas unglücklich aber die Abgrenzung
sagen wir mal wird sondern weil erhalten
bei Brand war ist nicht nur der Begriff
ein wenig unglücklich es ist einfach die
der Singular unglücklich es gibt nicht
eine Brandmauer man muss unterscheiden
zwischen Brand machen im Parlamenten und
Brand machen bei der Wählerschaft im
Parlamenten ist es so dass wir in die
nächsten zehn Jahren keine Koalition von
irgendeiner Partei mit der AFD sehen
werden jeder CDU-Politiker der sich der
AFD annähte stirbt sofort im idealen
Sperrfeuer und außerdem ist es einfach
so dass in der größte Teil der eigenen
Partei nicht folgern würde und nicht
zuletzt keine Partei wird vom AFD Land
Anhängern Wählern Politikern mehr
verachtet als die CDU die Grünen werden
wenigstens als Feinde ernst genommen die
CDU gilt den als ein Opportunisten
Haufen ohne Rückhand und ohne Konzept an
der AFD aus der AFD denn wenn die AFD
die stärkste Partei ist kann sie auf gar
keinen Fall mit solchen Opportunisten in
ihrem Augen ein Bündnis eingehen wo sie
nicht der Ministerpräsidenten stellt
Alter Sekunde Sekunde gleich dürfen sie
auf parlamentarische Ebene werden wir
alt parteien-koalitionen oder
minderheitskonditionen gegen die AFD
erleben das von diesen Koalitionen nicht
die CDU profitieren wird sondern die AFD
ist auch sehr klar die Bank mal bei den
Wählern freilich die hat nie bestanden
und die lässt sich auch nicht durchaus
grenzungen und so weiter erzeugen
solange die Wähler nicht den Eindruck
haben ein großer Teil der Wähler der
jetzt die AFD Welt nicht den Eindruck
hat dass man bei den etablierten
Parteien in dieser Stelle eher bei der
CDU besser aufgehoben wäre es bei der
AFD wird die Wähler Abwanderung sich
nicht stoppen lassen
also wenn man sich mit AFD Land
unterhält die überlegen natürlich schon
wie man am besten mal an die Macht
kommen könnte und da ist dann natürlich
die also die Union wäre die Macht Option
jetzt ist es zum Glück so dass man in
der Union das nicht als Option sieht
momentan aber ich würde sagen der Union
kommt hier an der Stelle nicht nur beim
Thema Brandmauer schon die wichtigste
Funktion zu aber auch also was die
Abgrenzung zur AFD betrifft wir sehen
jetzt ja auch dass es rhetorisch immer
wieder Ausbrüche gibt in Richtung AFD
wir haben sitz ich habe es am Anfang
angesprochen Energie Stasi einen
Ausspruch vom CDU-Chef in Thüringen das
suggeriert ja oder vergleicht die
Bundesregierung mit der DDR Diktatur was
ja was ist was für von der AFD so kennen
und es ist gefährlich sich dieser
Rhetorik anzunähern und dieses narrativ
zu lernen also da quasi ihre Partei
hinterher zu rennen die in unseren
Parlamenten sitzt und versucht die
Demokratie mit genauso eine Rhetorik von
innen heraus zu untergraben
ja ich wollte nur noch sagen die CDU wer
sich nicht gut beraten wenn sie sich mit
der AFD einlassen würde das haben wir
schon erlebt als die SPD sich mit den
Grünen letztendlich verbündet hatte sie
vorher bekämpft hat und dann aber die
Menschen natürlich an das Original
gewählt haben eben nicht mehr die SPD
sondern die Grünen die Grünen durch die
SPD stark geworden und sollte die CDU
mit der AFD zusammen gehen dann ist es
für wäre es für die AFD natürlich eine
Adelung und die Menschen würden also
eher das Original wählen als die CDU das
ist völlig klar das heißt da kann sich
für sich mehr sicher sein dass eben ein
Großteil der Partei folgen wird er dir
seinen guten Abend dafür verwendet das
ist nicht zu diesem Bier momentan schon
aber er ist ja auch am später Herbst
seiner politischen Karriere und es wird
auch eine Sachsen-Anhalt nachher ein
Haseloff geben und es hängt wirklich
sehr viel ab von der nächsten Generation
welches Gesicht die CDU und dann
präsentieren wird in Wäldern und wir
werden solche
Button glaube ich wer mit wem darf wenn
die Wähler es wollen und die Funktion
aber nicht weil wenn er oft führen
müssen weil letztendlich muss ja der
Wille des Wähler sich angemessen
wiederfinden und eine Koalition aus 45
Parteien permanente wechselnde
Mehrheiten ist glaube ich letzten Endes
auch nicht gut für ein politisches
System aber möglicherweise auch die
politische Zukunft in Thüringen war es
ja so dass bisher seine letzten Wahljahr
eine Minderheitsregierung also faktisch
war die
autoramelow ja zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen hat wir streiten uns weniger
obwohl schwierig ist als im Moment die
Ampel wir müssen hier einen Punkt machen
unsere Zeit ist nur für heute natürlich
abgelaufen ich bedanke mich bei Maria
Fiedler bei Reinhard Schlink hat bei
Werner Professor Werner Patzelt und bei
Alexander Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer das nächste aktuelle Phoenix
Geschmack so mal das kommt am Montag um
22:15 Uhr unter den Linden oder wird von
Michaela Kolster
aktuelles bei Phoenix der Tag mit Thomas
Bade darin unter anderem eine
Pressekonferenz zu der bevorstehenden
Übung der NATO Luftstreitkräfte er die
Fender
bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]